shirts dope yeah Hawaii that [ __ ]
great hitter the [ __ ] she did get why
you're dressed like honeymoon
well who would you be if you were on
bachelor you thing what kind of guy
would you be dude that's what everybody
wants to know I think if you were on
back be or question the big bachelor
she's like yeah it's just it's like
she's always messing around all the
goddamn time and then it's like I don't
know is it Jack Sparrow why CYT dressed
like a pirate altar is getting give the
pirate gimmick up or is he just giving
it start being real what kind of pirate
man the gayest pirate dude dude this is
I was in Utah you don't know how people
dress in different areas yeah I do man
you look like security firm Johnny Depp
Starks not the purple in the day yeah
back of his neck where man just for the
deaf do it for the deaf do it for the
depth I was you tall brother dude it was
nice man recharged feel pretty good went
kayaking um little whitewater rafting
yep saw a fox saw got to go to a
restaurant ooh
Utah's they're all about it yeah did
they go to I searched off some
appetizers yeah tell me what it's like
oh it's crazy man I even held the lady's
hand while I read the menu I thought I'd
start crying yeah I said we used to can
you can you to stand here and read it to
me is that Alright yeah god bless it
nice huh oh yeah yeah dude somebody
sneeze next to me I cheered the frosty
tip - yeah let's say big fat tip $18
[ __ ] yeah depend how many people did
walked in sat down sat next to somebody
accidentally bumped into somebody you're
living in the future
you're 2013 20 Corona it was crazy I
would say only one out of ten people in
u2 and
I was in southern Utah which is really
it's like more definitely a little bit
more of like the I don't want to say
like the Billy Ray Cyrus of Utah but
it's definitely kind of they're Mormons
with a bit of a twang huh yeah they're
more may if they're if they're Mormons
are more mountain Mormons yeah right now
yeah Mountain Goats kind of guy that
yeah a lot of mountain goats not a long
hair um free spirit crispy yeah they're
pretty free-spirited a lot of
dreamcatchers but pass out let saw
Stoney and st. George
you see doubt them yeah all the outlets
were closed down though oh but
restaurants aren't yeah well this we
actually went in a Springdale which was
a little bit more like in the mountain
by Mount Zion park and they had
restaurants open so jealous
it was pretty crazy I even ate 81
restaurant it was horrible I was like
this place is a [ __ ] but still
counts so old-fashioned yeah that night
tommy bahama hitter dug that r.i.p Kobe
shirt oh yeah and I never usually I
think I've only seen you in black yeah
you only wear black only wear black why
is that I don't know just it's just like
your outfit yeah like you look at my
closet it's just all black it's like you
and I exchange outfits today yeah I'm in
all black I never see you in black yeah
but it looks like they're on I switch
that [ __ ] out I knew you're gonna have
some sort of starting with the Johnny
Depp for your hair's gotten Black Pearl
problem what are you talking about this
is [ __ ] neck wear this is something
you talk neck wearing southern Utah the
youth here I'm saying you look like what
a you like Andre Agassi's hype boy
get the balls all excited for you give
them to look like Andre Agassi's DJ
love-love-love 40 1545 found pow pow
where do you play tennis that there's
fouls rough tennis bro Street tennis
dude it's got five it's got fouled out
of it so it's like he's out two hits one
foul what are you guys been doing what
are you been doing cat uh nothing much a
lot of baking but Wow
yeah I just don't know what to do with
all of it now you should have a bunch of
baked goods in there yeah like I'll have
a bunch of like banana nut muffins and
then just walk around trying to figure
out who to give it to my friend
Chappelle look at you like this no I
thought you were saying because of my
weight no I do your thick boy you're on
a diet right now yes I don't want to
bring it to the studio and like sabotage
me that way yeah yeah what I know you
just bacon for yourself really I bake
when I'm bored
Wow and so I just have a butt my
apartment is a bakery you know how you
can't be around cocaine I can't be
around banana bread really yeah let's
get in there that's the difference do
you chop it up you ever put some in a
headband and we're banana bread
no there's walnuts falling out of your
headband sir I love it man dude I've
been dealing with a lot of those dim
dirt serpents dude on the roads on the
trails really why bike clubs getting
real there's a lot of a lot of snakes
not every day this is this morning oh
wow that was that thick gardener snake
people like your if it's a rattler man
yeah nobody gives a D about a coral
gardener snake I don't know what the
[ __ ] it was you know I'd saw before you
could eat that thing if you wanted to
man the people I pick it up
don't be a [ __ ] pick that thing up like
[ __ ] I'm not not picking that goddamn
snake up
Vernon's like 40 feet away from it he's
filming us on a scope it's a drone shot
like you that's a garden a snake oh
[ __ ] scared you look like you sell
just murder Hornets on the dark web just
in Washington not anymore
find a new scene those [ __ ] murder
Hornets yeah pretty savage man
somebody's got to do it though man I'm
telling you bro God does what he does
ma'am
you think the economy's gonna shut down
for the murder Hornet he uses wild
animals that use whatever yeah you're
right who the big man upstairs said 2020
huh we got Jeff yeah we gotcha
Toby then corona and then the [ __ ]
murder murder Hornets man that could be
the end you seen the murder Hornets I'm
in the straight grappling Master the
[ __ ] Hornet you touch one there's two
[ __ ] sick yeah oh really yeah oh yeah
they're big dude and when they get you
there's nothing you can do about it my
boy coyote Peterson got stung by one he
says the most painful things ever been
stung by apparently there's hang out of
a like a regular honey bee hive and then
they want to come out they grab them
like in the air
yeah oh it's like Kabir yeah it's just
like a bee that looks like could be
right there actually very similar with
that arm leg constant movement
ground-and-pound murder Hornets look at
him go so they [ __ ] bees the four-inch
wrong dog don't [ __ ] up a badger they
have to picture one Chokin on a badger
why yeah and there's right there that's
their dead asian oh it's on yeah Japan
Japan can't they leave winged animals
alone the bat warned us not to have that
[ __ ] it is a stock cat murder wasps you
know what though what's up to if you do
you have your ear to the Asian realm
like what are you hearing from the east
I do have my ear to the Asian ground but
they don't let me in completely because
I'm american-born no they know you
didn't talk about on the show yeah I
hang out with too many white people now
they're like you're out officially
yeah dang they call it a meet song mama
mm-hmm me too
what it is yeah that's good that that
means ye in Vietnamese oh okay Whitey's
dude Co surprised you came over my house
I'm one of the don't speak Spanish steel
starts dropping Spanish like a
[ __ ]
well there was a single lady that speaks
Spanish in your house no it was look the
housekeeper yeah is my mother-in-law my
girl my kids is asking for single I'm
sure I could hook you up didn't [ __ ]
she seem single she said she was I
thought she said I don't know their
Spanish is off I feel like yeah I don't
make a move make a move I stuff with
flowers he thinks I'm their delft clean
and a mariachi band in that [ __ ] I
forget it yeah I forgot I hired a nun
brush my teeth at 7:00 in oh dude
therefore as my girl's birthday oh
that's always Cinco de Mayo oh yeah I'll
blow up today's your birthday oh it's
beautiful huh
[Music]
the Mitch's go hard in the paint man
then I'll look exactly the same and
they're all dressed like Sebastian
Maniscalco
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude you should've got her a burrow dog
a bull a burro donkey no like a little
dam gosh you got the expensive group huh
you played some jams the cheat group
they wrestle at the end oh I like that
you can that you can start got into that
forw dog do you hold that thing up
she just rent it for a day laughing
children of you salsa did you buy five
oh wow damn good hold babies five songs
500 paint after the third song you're
done after the first is all right that's
cool and then they kept Gonzaga alright
man
and then I've tried given to talk I mean
anybody worried about Corona he has a
pretty far apart is that what you worry
about and I don't speak Spanish heard
some about the Spanish flu though oh
yeah this guys are survivors from the
Spanish flu yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
built like armadillos the it's good a
beautiful little man armadillos in tuxes
dog yeah kind of handsome
yeah not bad they look exactly the same
nope maybe they're all manscaped look
man the world is changing man you know
that [ __ ] man
it is it is changing man that's like
aging quickly you got a ship fast dude
you gotta use ship station and we do
you're settled on money bro
yes so you sell online bro yeah shipping
online hey homes get a lot of orders out
fast it can be really tough you know a
ship station dog not anymore they got
the best rates a few clicks your manager
or just print out labels can your
product to happy customers shipstation
makes it so dang easy
you got a brought up ship station can
get it to someone it's the fastest
easiest most affordable way to manage
and ship your orders no matter what
you're selling Amazon Etsy your own
website ship station brings you all your
orders
simple interface making them really easy
to manage from any device even your cell
phone yup shipstation works with all of
the major carriers including USPS FedEx
UPS even Amazon Fulfillment so you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solutions for you and your customer
no wonder shipstation is number one
choice of online sellers you ship more
and less time with the best rates
available and right now Kingdom
stingless can try ship station free for
60 days when you use the code Kay ATS
make sure your business is ready to meet
the demands of the delivery culture get
start at chip station comm today yep
just click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in K 80s that's
shipstation comm then enter offer code k
80s ship station comm make ship happen
get ICS papa dude sometimes with my post
mates come I'm in tears really what you
would have to do when what you went
through to deliver this frickin tiramisu
is insane literally tiramisu with real
tears in it tears that's the kind of
stuff they'll offer mean they have
everything tell my post mates man
nothing better nothing better you want
cheese you want salami you want your
local favorite restaurant you want to
try a new restaurant you want support
the community a local restaurant do it
man
yeah they stay open yep you got to
support a man in one way to support them
and not have to drive over their post
mates postmates it and it's just not
food
maybe maybe you need pick some up at
Walgreens 7-eleven to drop it off right
outside your door yeah why drive
somewhere you could get into a head-on
collision now you don't even have to
worry about that let them take the risk
just download post mates on your phone
and you get anything you want delivered
within an hour and post mates has given
you guys $100 a free delivery credit for
your first 7 days start your free
deliveries download the app and use the
code k 80s 2020 that's right life is for
the living and you want to stay alive
and you want to eat whatever you want
whenever you want that's why you need to
use code k 80s to 0 to 0 for $100 of
free delivery credit for your first 7
days when you download the post mates at
anything you need
anytime you need it post mates it most
me what do we got Nick let's get into it
so last week we wanted to get an update
from Carly
Carlito with the Tito's
and she obliged and sent one in and we
haven't even addressed that Chin's not
here also chin passed away oh okay
Corona damn chin why he's wearing gonna
fight with some murder wasp and won and
won but he's pretty [ __ ] up like
Walter White if you were agent he he's
in all black huh
is he there Chin's there now we're
walking around doing some drinking can
he hear us other is yeah what's up dudes
hey daddy chin going on guys what's
going on dude we're so sorry that this
happened we all look we want you to know
that we don't think you did it and
mmm-hmm you know it's just a case of
mistaken identity man this is gonna pass
I don't think you killed those cats all
right yeah sorry about that
yeah you're a good guy man and we've
already all given statements to show our
support brother appreciate it man this
is the first time I've seen chin without
a mask yeah no one's here I'm gonna
studio by myself ah so you take the mask
off I'll take the pants off mask off
what's that song mask off is it really
hot pursuit oh yeah now Jim we have this
girl in the line here and you dated her
one point or you well you guys dated
yeah yeah but yeah she sent an update
after finding out some of the stuff do
you wanna hit play gin if you drink four
hundred dollars worth of sake
you dated y'all ready yeah hey guys I'm
doing well I heard you wanted a little
update on my life since we last spoke
and since we all found out that Jen had
a girlfriend
welcome anyone who'd date with me which
was very surprising she honeydicked but
I don't
reach-in and I hope it works out for you
a little advice though
don't do that but she's right thank you
for teaching me that apparently guys can
be any age and have a girlfriend and
still go on dates with women oh she's
not other than not like in pretty much
the same everything is now working from
home or at home so I'm getting a little
bored and I got all your member to get
back into the real world the sweater
puppies out girl I'm still dating and
I'm still on the market Theo oh I have
to go break from Garmin's [ __ ] scarfs
from Johnny Depp and go on a date
somebody wants to pet that trying to rub
the tip on the mullet trying to bounce
around in the steam style don't work
like that hog call hey Carl's trying to
get that queso mask oh yeah Chen what
about it then you tricked this girl into
going to a $400 just [ __ ] you sneak away
from your wife for a couple of hours I'm
a wife just my girlfriend but what do
you feel about her reaction I feel like
she came she was throwing a little bit
of ha but a shade a little bit of shade
I couldn't hear what she said so what
did you say like 40 year old she said
it's good to know that guys at any age
will lie and say they don't have a
girlfriend oh well I mean like you guys
already know it happened right after we
started this big no whatever I had to go
through with it so I apologize to her
one more time yeah yeah no no hard
feelings right chin no no I feel like
the hates on her side a little bit it
could be this whole corona thing too you
know like she's taken out on Asians it's
a popular thing to do
yeah that's true this is definitely are
you feeling a lot of heat right now Jim
being Asian and you guys being
responsible for a little bit of the
worlds demise kind of overall you know
as I told Brennan to Brian to you that
when I went to the market to the store
people will literally walk away from me
and not walk away from other people that
don't look like me yeah they're upset
now I know what that's like
apparently they're starting to call you
guys yeah they look kind of like come on
that shirt I think you're all right
should L wear that shirt Huey Lewis we
dude nothing else I like white people
have a Tommy Bahama shirt yeah they're
gonna you're gonna get especially the
night edition yeah girl Governors shirts
dope that [ __ ] great hitter the [ __ ]
she did good bro that shirt that's just
from downtown LA homeboys that's your
keep up with a box of wheat then it's
the widest box of [ __ ] fruit by the
foot don't go back to wearing black now
you doubled on your dress like Kobe
Bryant's honeymoon could ollie the [ __ ]
out on a skateboard right now though for
reals man with the fans the shirt dude
oh my god how do you should fell
well she's stepping out of the box yeah
yeah that's true man you trying
something different well Jim what do you
what do you say - Carly kind of throwing
shade your way you what you you know
honestly she has every right to be a
little bit a little bit she has a right
to throw a little bit of shade you're
good honey dhikr she wasn't gonna grab
me anyways right I was old for her she
had a delicious to our was it cream
barbecue dinner and so do you okay baby
something else hi I thought you're gonna
say listen we had a two-hour fun dinner
she has delicious tit
going I thought you were gonna talk
about those milk barns she's building in
her front yard there's very silos here's
what I'm telling you Chan and Flay
Lowe's yeah if you have a wife tell a
woman first that's all I'm saying
that's fair you know and that's fair
yeah I feel like a hot Karl times gone
by it's not Chin's fault you're single
and now she's shooting these [ __ ]
Tatas at Theo's way uh-huh they don't
work like that girls look I mean like a
nice girl I'll pay for the date Utley
yeah I'll pay for it but we got to be
able to film it I'll not do it do it you
know do for the show I don't know if I'm
ready to be dating right now dude I just
bought this outfit I feel like you
already
yeah I feel like that screams let's date
Johnny Depp gave the night off I'll pay
for it now I am what about his friends
huh
what about you just good you eat some
Korean barbecues friend I'm not driving
someone to meet a friend dude what do
you think it's [ __ ] 1800s right all
right I tried my best guys sorry team no
look I think it would be fun but I don't
know if I want to do it or not so
presents no you're doing hot Karl the
Dikembe Mutombo yeah Karl here's what he
said
where does she live out again Shin
where'd you leave her at I think she
lives around Newport Beach I remember a
beautiful Wow
some of the best maybe what's the kind
of the point if the virus dies down or
something oh well we're opening up on
Friday
maybe they don't Friday well I would
have to see if I can do it or no says a
lot excuse no I'll have to see if I can
do it
Chappelle let you borrow the shirt yeah
I will Brooke come on now come on this
will do you good
no yeah nothing sir
except playing hide-and-go-seek with
everybody and not telling them that I'm
doing it we're gonna Lakers game at the
node Cabana I know some Malibu rum if
you like Malibu rum you rock that shirt
chappal know what the [ __ ] you're doing
bro drink I appreciate the invite and if
I if I want if I decide to I'll hit you
up is that I'm not trying to be rude I
don't know you can go through me I'll
figure details there you go yeah let
Brandon Brennan will be the cube root
maitre d the middle man whooping can you
believe we your dark web yeah he'll be
the dark web um Keith at Easter just
went by through this thing you know he's
just like whatever no he did have a [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ] about anything
Easter there's been mass shootings yeah
there's been also somebody got mass
shooting dude nobody even [ __ ] cared
no the first the mass shooting post the
first comment was when can we get back
to restaurants yeah yeah winkin people
get shot in restaurants again yeah
that's what somebody asked like yeah
remember in the old days but at least
you would get you beat you'd be able to
eat while you got mass shot nice that's
the postman's man yeah like remember the
good old days
gin thank you so much for showing up and
we wish you were here man I wish I was
there to have fun guys and and don't let
the hot Karl get you down chin I won't
I'll be fine all right be good brother
hi guys stay safe
so look I overlooked I respect how she
handled it though man she came in she
looks beautiful she came in hot she came
in hot
like she does just broke Jews took a
shot she Steve Kerr did yeah well she
just said look I'm single she's I think
she's just overall letting men know that
she's available would you no no nope
nope she went till still single
Claire [ __ ] shot who nobody would
ever do that that's what she did dude in
my mind yeah she's trying like this
they aren't single and wink but in my
mind
was she getting stung by Mercker and
what did you take from what she said
let's get a female
she's definitely shooting her shot with
you and I also think that she isn't
necessarily upset with chin having a
girlfriend and not telling her cuz it
was the first date it's more so I think
she feels stupid because it's like yeah
it's a marriage that's embarrassing you
get set up on a date you go out on a
date with a married man who's 42 yes
well that my bad she didn't know either
Carl we didn't know either that's the
thing he hid everything from us too he
did he had everything from everyone
that's the thing about chin man you just
never know you're gonna get we have no
idea you know he's basically the Walter
White of Asia no idea let's uh let's see
what this guy has to say right here
thank you very much Carly for free
sending in the video after updating us
and can we set her up with guys I just
don't want something bad happening well
we can ask her what she's comfortable
with get it in writing cover her ass
yeah like non psychos you know we really
set her up with chin what's the worst
that she had a good time we did I felt
like she was down to mm-hmm once you got
that sake in her chinga a weird two is
the one I wish I liked a chance thanks
to you I'm married standing outside by
the traffic kicked out of the restaurant
Lord's blind date I've ever seen he was
blind by the end bro enough sake made
Ching go blind bro he went fully mind
just come in see after long that's gotta
be crazy if you really um must be fun
though you know yeah must be fun okay
alright here's the guys got a question
let's get into it
here's our first King at our sting it
hey guys what's going on - John from Los
Angeles we're just a little podcast big
fan so I got a king interesting for you
guys so it's been recently released that
they're gonna have Nicolas Cage play Joe
exotic and the scripted series that's
coming out and I'd love to know what you
guys think and can Nicolas Cage pull
this off can he portray the legendary
Joe exotic what do you guys think man
I'd love to know king at our sting it
Nicolas Cage playing Joe exotic in the
scripted series gang gang buzzbuzz
buzzbuzz young Andrew I love me some
Nicolas Cage he really doesn't miss and
she started going broke to his body like
castles and snakes and [ __ ] they started
doing some bad movies but this was kind
of he's gonna knock this out the park I
was hoping to be dak Shepherd I feel
like you've been a really good Joe
exotic yeah kind of has that like
white-trash vibe you know yeah yeah yeah
accent seem a little Nicolas Cage's
could actually really make it amazing
that's the thing like Dax I think could
make it kind of good like it'll be
interesting yeah but cage could really
leave that I mean he might be able to
make an amazing man yeah Nicolas Cage is
the RT right he's an artiste Bros and my
boys thick though I've seen lately he's
Jack not a no not Jacqueline he's
getting oh he's put on weight
yeah fat that well maybe that's not a
thick with three C's a thick right K
okay yeah and then did you see when he's
get the last time I saw him outside of a
movie he was didn't get married and him
and his wife or Fiat they started
arguing mine in Vegas and she stormed
off oh he's had trouble in love man he's
had trouble in love he's in my favorite
movie family man he's probably one of
the 13 or probably 15 best actors ever
hands down face off damn I didn't say
this off take your face off really think
if you and I exchange faces that's face
off dude well that's all those things
that Brian monarch does also yeah you
ready what was the one he was in with
Dave Chappelle was Kate he had the long
hair you know oh [ __ ] dude Connor Connor
Connor haven't seen that hope is
Chappelle and Connor
mmm-hmm I gotta see this he put the
bunny back in the box
uh-huh they beets it kills the Uyghurs
told you about
the Barney uh is it a real bunny no it's
his daughter stuffed toy
I think this cage is in this john
malkovich so good in that Cyrus the
virus being arranged already touches Oh
Dave Chappelle pinball and he kills him
he gets stuck in the poor on the wing
Bouchet Sheba she's great in it too
danny trejo and he's in every movie but
well i love it man I love it I say King
and I think Cage is gonna knock out of
the park
I can't think of a better one dak
Shepherd is my only go to but that
wasn't solid one right there Nicolas
Cage is [ __ ] good here we go right
here this tears miles teller that's cool
yeah what up guys hope you guys are
surviving quarantine all right grateful
for the podcast while I'm at home doing
nothing
I got a candor sting it re dosing Bert I
don't know if I heard you guys talk
about it I know it's been a while but uh
what do we say can't get her sing it
Gang Gang buzz-buzz shutout big boy bike
club shout-out Dicky damn the movement
shut up Vicky those drops Friday to do
does it yeah it's a gift it's a shitty
gift I have but it's a gift is that that
guy a miles teller yep it's a real [ __ ]
just I have that's a good one
I'm like Rain Man mm-hmm so like take
down that picture yeah shitty gift that
um already dosing Burt you want to dive
into this first I think that Burt likes
any height that he can get I think he's
okay with it in the end I think it was a
little risque in the beginning my
problem is doing it around his family if
it was like on the road or something
that's whatever cuz they're so close he
did it that's whatever the problem is
there's no consequence like if I already
did that to me in you Jasper just around
my kids there's gonna be repercussions
that's the problem
he knows Burt's not gonna do anything
yeah you do that to Rogen there's gonna
be repercussions yeah you have to Tom's
probably be repercussions
but Burt's so fun and playful that Burt
you know and Burt does they're close
though so it's like they're bought like
you would never do that to me
right and every crazy would never do
that to me but again I I don't know the
relationship well enough but I you and
me are close you're my best friends if
you Brian or Rogan death to me dude I'd
have put my hands on you yeah especially
in front of my kids I would get lucky
I'd do it just to get beat probably oh
there's no about that bro just to feel
something you know people aren't feeling
it huh sting it but again but if I you
know re they may he may play around we
play around like that rights like I
don't know the relationship so if that's
how they play around Who am I to say
they should have done it he's like the
Santa Claus kind of drugs he like kind
of shows up people don't know if he's
real and then he [ __ ] drugs you you
know hmm
I know Bert was I heard Bert was upset
but then he seems alright what then he
seems alright with it yeah so he said he
said he had some medical problems but
he's always had those I think since up
no oh god that's his weight right yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's why they said they
were gonna replace his heart at one
point
oh sure with like a calf heart or
something and then he's uh there but he
was going playing to it to go out and
play nothing he's not dude it sounds
like these guys a couple of [ __ ] boys
that's what it sounds like do they need
a brother [ __ ] also words too old to be
doing mom [ __ ] that's the other thing
well what was it it also depends on what
type of drug it was it was Molly it was
a shitload of Molly or II I don't know
drugs is that the same she gets fine
dude it's just gonna end up in a big-ass
family hug and as long as they get you
out of the house after an hour I think
you're good you know it seems like no no
harm no foul I've been pissed I don't
play like that dude I've grown with kids
I can't that can't play like that
did it happen though do you guys think
out part of me wonders if it was
strategic to help you get hype for a
special though and to help get a re past
the Kobe thing no this was before the
cousin was oh nevermind me this is
before all that I think that's the
relationship yeah if that's what they do
mask off yeah they've got a podcast
recorded that they never released Burt
thinks it'd be like irresponsible or
something but man that would crush
everybody knows about this it's like
legend now they need to release that
bird says he doesn't want to release it
cuz ya say some he was really upset at
him right yeah he was worried that like
it would be bad influence on children
about drug like he's taking it lightly
he doesn't know if there's legal
repercussions he said which i think is
not really an issue oh cool children
yeah local children international
children once it's insane and you're
gonna be too upset if they're still boys
yeah that's this thing you didn't put
any hand bro if you're upsetting them
[ __ ] shoot him Yeah right
shoot him cut him cut him shank him yeah
yeah what are you gonna do oh you did
nothing bro you did nothing you ain't
upset cuz i'm high you probably look
like banana bread to me I'm like the
[ __ ] oh yeah at least bite into your
buddy's neck bro yeah dawg teach him a
lesson
yeah bite in your [ __ ] friend nothin
Bert yeah you did nothing Bert
speaking of banana bread we've got a
name game haven't done this in a while
sending more of these these are fun just
another mustache here we go soon Cortina
are hot Oh
so guys we live in LA and all bets have
been off during kovat as far as diet
goes a little name game for ya
deserts Gang Gang buzz buzz peace out
hmm that means guys the limit here what
are the rules of this game again any
dessert there you go man after dinner
you can't say fruit by the foot kids
named candy yeah those are desserts
let's be legit desserts okay take it off
yep that's what I was gonna say man it's
a vegetable cake you know it's you know
it's healthy and it's cake um I will go
with bread pudding lemon meringue pie
with another nice one yep creme brulee
I'm gonna say coconut cream pie berry
there's not a lot of blueberry on the
menu great there's a apple pie you know
everybody got that Apple hit are you
burning in that book you bringing that
beat as fire right here when everybody's
happy a good apple pie you start living
bro you chop more desserts wrong what if
you come around here with that dude
they're not tiramisu you later
don't make me hit you with that peach
cobbler is what I really like is that
Larry up with some tiramisu Trevor how
about that nice just the put I like a
nice plain vanilla scoop hey you like
Sandra Bullock yeah what's up with that
movie with her eyes look like you you
look like you're gay box not tiramisu so
our ball hitter owes it so many Beauty
mmm is so hard ice cream layups
dude fried I saw you regular ice cream
melted ice cream ice cream pies when
train sandwiches with
that's the most Midwest thing ever has a
here's a handful of whipped cream
the are whipped cream if you're trying
to help you get some nice [ __ ]
berries a little whipped cream on top oh
yeah I've been too brother
dude I can't Lisa tiramisu tell me know
I can want with chocolate cake yeah
anyone has that chocolate cake oh you
could have a triple chocolate cake
double chocolate devil's chocolate
German chocolate German chocolate cheese
came down then the cheese carrot that
pound cake Mexican chocolate vanilla do
I love ya tres leches dog three mils bah
get that melt shake hitter oh you know
chilies get a full rack of ribs and wash
it down with a chocolate shake and they
have molten lava cake they're too damn
hot covered bananas you bailed out
Mizuki oh man yeah you could mmm how'd
you what happened how do you say to your
me so what cuz when your name and I'm
thinking so I didn't hear you really say
tiramisu I heard your other one I think
said tapioca pudding oh yeah can what
with bread pudding chocolate pudding
vanilla pudding those no cheese oh yeah
Chinese dessert it's Japanese but that's
a nice try it is yeah oh wow close
enough it's good I did it in China dude
that's how much I like it
I really would let's see what this guy's
to say this guy's seems like he's
definitely I'm so upset why I'm shocked
you let you laugh so I have sweet teeth
yeah this I don't have enough video it's
not that we're gonna be here all day
we should have been I dropped the ball
down I shot my shot a mess it's alright
man what's up guys so I got it a big
clip for you so I'm just taking a break
watching this guy talk about how we just
loves tugging on his pecker and I'm
gonna have a little string cheese the
debate club is when you eat string
cheese do you peel it back like a young
schoolgirl or do you just bite it into
that [ __ ] like a goddamn man debate it
dude looks like you a little me a little
I don't mix
what do you think a younger Brendon I do
not look like that count looks like my
buddy veteran from eclair you guys knew
him you'd think I was Brendan right now
with the bedrock do not pull up the
drove probably clear we already have
enough pending litigation what a great
name though that's a real friend dude
you just made that up from Eclair okay
he still naming dessert dude that's
right well we didn't get the donut God
Brandon what happened to you man
something happening while I was out of
town years ago you would have known dead
hairs ago they Jeremy sir is that your
buddy
smuggle drugs for the cartel across the
border dude I eat string cheese like a
goddamn civilian of course I'll its
stream cheese yeah its string its string
for a reason man and you didn't like a
goddamn educated man you think Elon Musk
is byte nothing like a [ __ ] caveman
no dude he's peeling it like an educated
soul how do you guys do it in the far
east cat what are you guys doing uh well
we're really good luck with dairy right
Asian people are usually lactose
intolerant no we still eat cheese the
more you know gangster we don't really
care about that but we're really good
with following instructions so you
always gotta peel it mmm and Chappell
see I didn't have string cheese until I
was adopted into the white family right
oh it's a white tonight yeah that's why
it's a whitest name yeah I've never had
a bad life ever do a pickle maybe in a
little thing you know you see a like a
lot yes yeah I prefer black treats yeah
you do like treat oh yeah what are black
treats it would be like oh yeah you said
the hot dog
the trustee at the river trust tree we
are until Shabazz nugget a little
comfortable you got there at night time
Tommy Bahama shirt my bad yeah she fell
if you're here you like don't worry your
white costume ain't no FUBU makes
[ __ ] exotic for Uruguay buy your head
I know Karl Kani makes [ __ ] outerwear
ocean edition debate club Pele string
cheese or bite it peel at 70 degrees and
of course dude what time the finals when
you bite it I noticed that it's kind of
shaped like it's they make it so you're
supposed to peel yeah yes the way it's
kind of like it's like kind of tapered
at the top you know in layers yeah that
thing's ready to be peeled and instead
of just to bypass all of that it's just
bite into it with some terrorist [ __ ] -
that's is this movie very Isis man it's
really it's just bizarre fella what's
that guy's name fed drum it's almost
upsetting - yeah yeah bedroom dude you
can buy in a chatter like that yeah
Merilee had the cheese off who lost that
one no is it and then I lost unsweet
that's unbelievable unreal unreal unreal
I'm so disappointed I thought you're
gonna win that wasn't upset I thought it
was a layup I'd be the first scene yeah
there's not a lot of blueberry you could
have went with cherry mmm yeah I said
coconut cream dude that's so good
a banana banana custard banana custard
banana rhubarb pie just your cobbler
flavorless gelatin flavorless yeah you
can get some jello I guess it's kind of
a cheap snack dog I mean it's good I
shouldn't use sugar-free Joe that's what
bodybuilders eat for sweet tooth they do
apparently Orange County Choppers is
back what's up gentlemen good morning to
you CEO Brendan I love what y'all doing
man a lot of podcast got a lot debate
club for you so I'm originally from New
Orleans Louisiana
but I do I even went down that causeway
spent my time and that st. slamming II
you know zap now I'm in Salt Lake City
Utah so here's my debate a lot of people
here love going hiking and seeing the
mountains for what they worth and going
out there doing their thing back home
you know it's water and Gulf Coast and
seeing which you can cut up on that
Bayou so man here's my debate
what's better than Huygens in the
mountains or is it better just to chill
not by you yeah let me know what you
think figured it was a perfect debate
for y'all from where y'all from all
right let me know
gang guzzle but muzzle that's a
scary-looking man today at Mozilla that
boy did some time he did we think you
did broke a few necks still see his
tattoos at Louisville Slugger
probably stole some choppers for parked
and he's not even from Louisville yeah
that guy's done see look at that he
prolly definitely the boys doing the
Lord's work on the street oh yeah I'm
glad he's a fan I'll tell you that right
now
[Laughter]
yeah that dude is huh you know he drives
a hog I do this thick lush a nice ammo
line for the Utah blaze that arena leaf
is it I played for them you really did
bring up the you tell blaze emblem if
you can I don't think the team's there
anymore
I think they really went under but yeah
there was a team called the Utah blaze
Wow how many games you play uh I was in
a season nope I was in camp got my
jersey and then halfway through camp was
a great how much we paying us I was
miserable they wanted me get to 300
pounds Wow we still have the Arizona
Rattlers do you mm-hmm
yeah he chopped Utah place Boise burn I
think was a team to I think I remember
and then I remember everyone the locker
rooms they paid us I think like
25 grand that was the most we got and
everyone was like well you know Kurt
Warner started here I mean oh I get it I
get it dude we're doing dinner fell
we're all thick is fun is that not
common for people to go to NFL what what
I mean it's over dude Wow chapter you
tall place
uh listen mayonnaise I'm uh as president
think boy bike club I gotta pick you
talk is the biggest some of the best
trails out there in the world and I was
just on their trails that's the thing
man I mean I still have dirt all over me
from there mm-hmm still got the scarf or
sweat on it yeah this thing is a hundred
percent Utah from Utah man and it's
Mormon oh it's everything out there they
got polygamy too out there and here's
the thing that they'll do I learned this
is a polygamous housing trick they will
have a a man will get a wife okay then
they will get a house for the wife but
they won't complete the house they won't
finish the building of it and if it's
not finished then they don't have to pay
property taxes on its own you can still
be a functioning house but if it's not
completely finished and you save that
money can say just save a little bit of
bank you know trip in the system mmm and
I think Mormons should be able to have
their own country if they want I think
if they basically do yeah the Presidents
Tom Cruise yeah some dope laying there
not being a scientist Scientology or
chilling the body another by you though
you can get bit easy here's the problem
to buy you them Gators said I can't
relax in the body you will be a snicker
out there you'd be a vanilla snicker
you're right Mormons don't pay the taxes
either though any any religion is tax
exempt Zowie they all tie if you're
right right I'm still off today though
boy yeah you get snagged on out but also
if you're not in the super healthy
lifestyle Utah into place New Orleans is
yeah you go to that Bourbon Street
you're that old bar where it's all dark
there's just candles you were absurd
sibel you get free drinks all night so
you fit in there anyway first of all it
LSU colors yes you colors you get a you
saxophone in one hand you get drinks all
night so I got a saxophone [ __ ] yeah
yeah you know Lisa Simpson tattoo on
your back or Krusty the Klown mother
waiting kill me the lights out hell yeah
dude I think I love the Bayou man I love
being able to fish though that's one
thing that's in the mountains you got to
come down from the mountain of fish
because they don't have a lot of Lake in
the mountain there's some fishin though
and you told them but those fish have to
climb up the mountain and they barely
even wet when they get up there you look
kind of dehydrated by the time they do
get up yeah there are fish stick you
might find a couple fish deep-fried man
I mean it's just different both you race
they're both great but your boy being a
biker I'm picking you Tom yeah respect
man so there's not a lot of gang
activity in like you're not getting too
much trouble in Utah the by you get some
trouble man yeah if I get my tits out
you get married down there people
killing each other a lot more every
gangling episode is in New Orleans first
48 starts in New Orleans I asked doing
that some of that method Louisiana
madness want glass they call it I think
man I'm gonna go you table fresh out of
Utah at the moment you know come on Utah
man I'm still got that elevation in my
lungs so I'm gonna stay in Utah man Utah
it'll be wait here john burroughs a
freakin savage brah and you tell us you
have a professional football team which
is alarming well the use of Utah blaze
but they weren't but I'm not I'm not you
took away the Harlem well I'm not
talking like Harlan Orleans Saints and
then college football the youth ain't
bad you keep saying oh I go to the you
[ __ ]
the you is you never see Miami you guys
need to quit that [ __ ] you talk you're
not the real you you is University in
Miami but you go down there they do tell
them it's not the real you you get
[ __ ] really
yeah but Utah State also the Cougars I
think is their team name nope Utah State
Aggies
oh wow hmm but they got some a lot of
decent schools out there BYU yeah
yeah bring um young baby BYU all
Hawaiians all white boys and they can
play some ball oh yeah there's a couple
black some not many I said a couple is
it really good yeah pineapple blacks
it's what they call a lot of the
Hawaiians yeah you're right Utah has
some ballers though like Alec Smith came
from there you know what happened Alex
makes a Smith you know happened him I I
didn't either
I was watching ESPN 60 they have that 60
show on there and so right bulb for San
Fran then [ __ ] homeboy came out or if
he's taking me mm-hmm
Kaepernick so that I kill he's probably
the future he went to from there he went
to the Chiefs and then he got hurt then
I got his patch from my home so he's
falling patching homes then they're like
all we're all set dude we got patching
with homes
he said well [ __ ] goes he goes to
Washington signs like a three-year
hundred million dollar deal six game of
the year
hut hut hike JJ Watt tackles him
compound fractures his legs and the way
he got tackled it like broke all his
[ __ ] you know standard leg injury he was
the hospital
two days later they do surgery he's like
me I'm trying to get back home that guy
you can leave today he's like I don't
feel great though so they take his
temperature he has like 104 temperature
and something's going on they look in
his leg he got some on the field because
dirt gone there you got some eating
flesh-eating bacteria they show the
pictures it's insane dude he's done done
damn oh that is the flesh-eating
bacteria tore up his leg so bad
they were like man if we don't
decapitate his leg in the next day or so
he's gonna die so his wife was like well
then take the leg but then I guess some
medication worked and so his legs there
but he's [ __ ] they took money took
skin early took muscle from his other
leg to put on this leg
Wow yeah it's a sad story yeah what has
money though at least you know you're
not dead oh yeah hundred million a
Redskins wow gosh so sorry the pictures
rough dude that's our breaking yeah
alright P Alex Smith man but still doing
the damn thing I had that dimepiece wife
in the documentary - yeah a lot of
beautiful women out there dude I'm so
bored and course you now watch don't
[ __ ] with cats
ice now did you yeah my [ __ ] was
fantastic what sons of anarchy I've been
binge-watching man why don't you read or
read a desert book you're right dude you
write sons of anarchy
go back this 2000 set they'll throw on
that sugar shade over here boy you are
the car though I know your sweet teeth
oh stop dude I got it
what's this [ __ ] POG talking about is
there a last debate club
[Laughter]
yeah I wish dog I wish I jump on a hog
and feel comfortable they're too
dangerous though man and I need a
workout son I feel like you've been
motivating you have been a motorcycle
before man I've had a couple of
occurrences I got thrown off of one on
the side of like a hill one time pretty
dangerous I'm not trying make funny bomb
assume when you're the guy in the back
holding you buddy not too fast I wasn't
one of those side cars one time and
somebody set it on fire when I was in
there that was a little bit what was the
debate club just motorcycles motorcycles
or bicycles
Oh buy so he's trying to get lean and
mean bicycles son motorcycle doing all
the work it's like that a bike I didn't
sweat just yeah I don't need bike this
weekend it's definitely not it's not the
rough and tumble thing you want you're
trying to get them quad teardrop hitters
you gotta get on that bike and put in
the work son
get that blonde ass like Theo you gotta
put in the work Jesus Christ put the
work somewhere else dude it's all on my
butt that dude look dope on a bike
though they do look hon look sweet on my
bike didn't I just see some Pelle being
on a hog yeah see if I told you I've
been binge-watching sons of anarchy yes
you know get out there man you gotta get
out there kid in the Hells Angels okay
yeah they don't let black people in
there huh but change that is that a rule
is that a rule I
yeah I think so no black people Hells
Angels are they racist now who's the
all-black one not the mom blind answers
not the Black Panthers because they
don't have motorcycles there's an
all-black one there's some bad boys dude
type in all black motorcycle gang I see
I see him invent motorcycle club there
not again not again call me game hits on
the face black motorcycle club black
rebel nope black rebels are dead to ban
or maybe look up at maybe try
african-american maybe just type in
black more second cycle gang it's black
motorcycle gang right right just I've
been gang for the sake of it
you'll see I'm not calm again but that's
you got to put buffalo soldiers I said
nope that's not who I'm thinking of
doing well it's a big one yeah that's a
big one
well a few guys man because I'm trying
to meet some hot chicks dude dude they
have hot chicks they're called they're
called old lady old lady old lady's and
they gotta wear their names on their
back of the shirt property of that's it
do they have a lot of Vietnamese bikers
motorcyclists yeah that's all we do over
in Vietnam everyone drives a motorcycle
I actually have a burn on my leg from
motorcycle when I was in Vietnam
I got burned by the exhaust pipe when I
was like six damn it's like a rite of
passage almost kind of yeah I think it's
the Vandals is that on there look when
you advance as a band when you and
nicker done flirting with each other the
rest of us are trying to find out about
Vietnamese by cyclist what just do me a
favor to the moth today is it the
Vandals because I saw on the road as a
black guy what plan who ride gas-powered
cycles but that's not a gang bro man
blows baby
the Vandals pop up it's also a biker
there you go vandals MC yes o pagans
motorcycle club
hey no the Vandals that's them dude yeah
I saw a couple on the road they meet
they meet in Venice and I was scared and
I looked them up hmm those are white
people handles those are a lot of white
guys I don't know
look I know tears tara misu say that
much really
I know tara misu well see I'm glad you
got some rest man you don't think I knew
that need a vacation during the
quarantine man I'm exhausted bro I have
to take off for a few days like from
what Oh
[Laughter]
dude oh you know what I did see so a lot
of the businesses were closed they had
deer just like wandering around like
inside of like just parking lots and
stuff things you would be like oh this
is like a weird place for some deer they
had a like a La Quinta Inn and by the
pool and stuff they had deer just
drinking out of them pretty crazy there
get a little too comfortable yeah
deer up in the hot tub the Mormons get
back to work let me lighten those deer
up yeah man choke them out I would love
to start a male all-male or also some
chase can come now where you fight
animals where people wave to fight
animals one on one or hunt one on one
you know hands with your hands yeah or
with a knife one knife you think people
would do it sounds like naked and afraid
we're just boys yeah also chasing come
at night I'm in yeah but do you think
people would do it no too scared to kill
what are we waiting kill with your bare
hands right it's tough a couple of
warthogs maybe snakes but there be some
you really see sue who could be some
good hunters you have to grapple them
[ __ ] murder Hornets dude or go
noodling well I'll try to put your hand
on [ __ ] yeah this mouth its catfish
right yeah yeah that's popular in
Vietnam isn't it
no that's New Orleans I feel like oh
yeah I know it's popular down there but
I'm talking about I've seen it done a
bunch in Louisiana Mississippi Oklahoma
does it big-time big-time Oklahoma what
exactly is it noodling where they put
their hand in a pipe that has a fish in
it and they get the fish out well it's
like a it's like a mud it's like
underwater and like a lake or a [ __ ]
river and they put their whole handing
cuz if you don't it has stingers so
there you go ever tried noodling no they
don't you gotta get in there those boys
don't get caught and then you eat them
huh
[Laughter]
it's okay the girls where's my shirt I
bet you can name a few desert I bet you
went [ __ ] tara misu staring at the boys
in the lipstick look at the milk in
Jungle fronts on that boy
yeah Christmas Christmas Bunny Christmas
critter huh he's not in the shot huh the
man in the shot they clearly don't know
him he's not even after nothing he just
showed up he's trying to feel on these
he says take your shirt off and feel on
them boys next top model exotic farm
League no dude I need to catch up editor
son want to have a seat that's crazy why
is that guy I doubt he signed off on
that full body what do you mean you
don't show up to something looking like
that if you didn't plan on it
this is tinder profile pic very tender
dude that is rare food let him live man
let him live he's living doing a damn
thing and he used to probably be a train
conductor obviously and here he is man
obviously we lives in one of those
Christmas villages at our grandparents
owned gosh I thought this dude died in
the Andrea Gail oh that's it man Brennan
and the old fighter and wait I gotta go
in and go hard in the paint I do not
think
and flows black rifle coffee I'm ready
to go I need a sponsor I am a monster
about to open up with this at my
concerts flow is contagious browser
outrageous thicker than girls leather
Instagram famous damn I'll be like a
fresh off keto see a red like Andrew
Santino every Sunday is like the great
Bambino we're gonna take the case oh and
the case Cerritos but everything's gonna
be fine
hate on me I do not mind the type of
dude got a pack of matches in his
pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
Trevor couldn't beat em quit playin like
that's in DoDEA's you don't want the
smoke like Joey Diaz meaning y'all
edible just got my eyebrows threaded and
I'm feeling incredible Brit and Sun him
me up he said it's true loud in the club
can you pick me up
sting
oh yeah and the sting bee sting cracking
Anna sting King an estate
got that cheese on a string
and the sting King in the stink
and the sting bee sting Rat King
and the sting a king and a state of
bees-cheese
mystery spinning and do fighter in
creole shoutout New Orleans and
shout-out to Co Colorado more
specifically Boulder Brendan came in
with a chip on his shoulder but is still
gold and yet it still fire refute all I
King Aniston you're a liar Brendan's got
like a thousand different hustles one of
them's that Norse director when ty yours
black rifle club VP hear you loud and
clear
your son on the email like please get me
out of here is way too naughty here
watching the Irishman eating pizzas
drinking half a beer now under Theo von
looking like the tepid do the trans
Arita songs smoking cigarettes with a
snapback on but to hit the crib in
charge snapchat on it's all good we
still mess with you 18:11 Pico Boulevard
go get the head Derek and cat y'all
doing great Thursday upload not a minute
late y'all wanted to wrap a head a
demonstrate brand new studio y'all
feelin great putting Chris Delano in
this place now let's go and get you a
game and sting
and the sting
and the sting bee sting cracking
stinking and stable fees in the truck
got that cheese on a string doggy in the
stink bad King in the stinking is a
sting bee sting
and the sting okay and the sting got of
bees in the track got that cheese on a
strong
[Music]